[Music]
thank you very much thank you all for
being here the greatest of the British
men one of the two the other was William
Shakespeare I suppose sir Sir Isaac Sir
Isaac Newton has given us a
extraordinary tool for dealing with with
reality we still use Newton equations
for building bridges and air plants and
everything else but especially has given
us a vision of what is real what is
reality a way of thinking about reality
which in fact it's at the basis of his
equation and which is unbelievably
simple and beautiful and convincing and
we all already sort of have in our mind
which is the following there is a huge
empty space right which has no special
direction up or down all the same is the
same all over and so it's a sort of
tablet which is supposed to represent
the space so it's equal and goes for
okay so that's the stage and on the
stage
time passes for the space time time
passes equals since ever forever and all
the thing we see can just be soaked as
bodies or particles move around and they
move straight in space forever
until something pushes so pull them
forces Newton forces and these forces
are generated but I think I suppose are
the particles so that's it space times
and particles and this is a really
fantastic and phenomenal if you think
because the enormous complexity of
everything we see neuron asks us to
think that it can be reduced to just
space-time and particles and nothing
else now his idea of course is they
of course is not completely new Newton
recognized that he took it from ancien
thinkers from the unsent Adam astir and
Democritus in particular but Newton was
able to transform it using mathematics
using experiments using transform it
into a exodia a powerful general picture
of reality which we can actually use and
most modern word world has been based
into into it unfortunately the books of
Democritus are all lost our civilization
has the misfortune we have all of our is
total and unknown of Democritus we only
know him through some some indirect
sources and from indirect sources the
Newton got this picture those pictures
fantastic but science is not about
discovering how reality is is
discovering how realities and then
discovering more and then more and then
more and looking father and father and
in fact this picture turns out to be
incomplete in exact approximate and what
I want to give you in a half an hour
less it's a story of how this picture
has changed then still changed so the
first change it will be in three or four
steps the first change is still a
British man in fact two British men a
wealthy Scottish and poor working-class
Englishman which are Michael Faraday
that the poor Englishman and Sir James
Clerk Maxwell how when particles attract
what matter it's not really that there
is something mysterious going from here
to here there is something in between
which is electric field electric field a
magnetic tip so what is the electric
field and the magnetic field what is
something which is all over it's
something that in which we are immersed
then let me just represent it nice
another piece of fabric
and when a particle attracts one another
what is really doing sort of pulling and
pushing the field which in turn spools
and push the particles and Max will
write the equations for the field how
this things move and so these are the
the beautiful worlds
world of noodle has changed now it's not
just space and time of particles but the
space-time particles and the field and
is a huge triumph I mean all the
equations of electromagnetism that we
use all our technologies based on micro
equation but it's much more than that
first of all as I believe all you know
neutralizes that the vibrations of the
field the field vibrate moves is light
right light is just a field but rapidly
vibrate which means that if your teacher
told you that you cannot see the fields
it's obviously false we see only the
fields right because we see light I I
don't see you I see the light that comes
from you the molecules of your body
vibrates and the field vibrate and
lights come to my eyes and that's how I
know you're there so I only see the
yellow here physics is beautiful so and
so this vibrate but that's not enough
max I realized that behind besides that
the fast vibration they feel they're
also slow vibrations and he said well
you can produce it with antennas and
stuff and in fact they were found later
on and these are the radio waves with
which we have radio TV communications or
all modern communication technologies
based on an object the radio waves and
the moving of the field that was not
discovered was understood to exist
before detecting it by by much of this
power of the reticle physics so here we
are it's a new world this is the Newton
plus the electric fields but then just a
few decades later this changes again and
this time is not British sorry it's
German sorry and and and and the J what
does a German do well German realize
his name is Einstein Albert Einstein
theorized that if things attract one
another they also tracked of course
nobody knew gravitationally like this is
the Sun this is the earth it pulls it so
there should be also gravitational field
well there should be another field right
not just dominating field but a
gravitational field now Ashton had only
added another field he would have been a
great good physicist but not the genius
he is so why he was just because he
understood something else and what is
understood is that there is indeed a
gravitational field let me put this
aside because otherwise I get confused
but I don't have so many ants but this
gravitational field is already in the
picture and is Newton space so what I
understood is that Newton space is not
such a rigid object like this thing
pretending to be a tablet it let me take
away the rigidity it's a field itself we
can also move and be squeezed and make
waves and be stretched and be pulled
likes electric field is exactly the same
thing and to the extent in which it
remains still is Newtonian space so
Newtonian space is nothing else
the gravitational field when we
disregard the fact that it's moving in
other words the space in which we leave
this flat uniform still think the stage
that Newton imagined is not at all a
flat fix at the stage something moving
we're not living on a stage we're living
on some oscillating thing which can be
bent and can be pulled and stretched and
there are waves which are the
gravitational waves which we now
indirectly detect there are curvature
there's curvature of space this
curvature can be so big that you could
make a hole that's black holes and so on
and so forth it's not just space that
curves have been cutting short the
animals here will be this space-time so
it's not just the extension space but
the passage of time which are bent what
does this mean well let me
a simple picture of that so take a clock
and take another one and they make sure
they indicate the same time they do okay
now lower one keep it lower for a while
wait a moment
then bring it up look at them closely
and if they're good enough clocks these
are not good enough to close my
grandfather but if there's a good enough
clocks they don't indicate the same time
the one who's been lower is late which
was fun the one that has been up which
means the times come over here and an
upper here this is a this is something
eyelids I stand on this to disco but now
it's not some stranger device it's
nothing which is verified in the
laboratory pretty easily and irregularly
even a few half a meter of so time
doesn't pass the same time passes slower
down faster here if you think a moment
the reason the actual reason for which
thanks for ok the longest rate they come
down is because time passes a different
speed up here than here so it's more
convenient timewise to go up and down
rather than go this way which if you
think is the same reason for which when
you fly from London to New York and if
you look at the map you know the map of
the earth right and here's London here
is New York and then you look at what
the airplane does it does that so why
the stupid spy electricals always up
there well because yours is round so if
you go on about if you're gonna wanna go
from east to west err it convenient to
go north because the distance between
and west meridians is smaller north so
this is actually shorter than this the
same reason for which this is shorter
than this space-time is curved so it's
convenient to go up and down rather than
go straight this is a the hardest part
of this story so if you haven't got this
time thing it's just retained the idea
of space and time occur
okay so here we are after 1915 Albert
Einstein the German this is our world
now this gravitational field there is
electromagnetic field and they're
particles and there's no space and time
anymore space and time are just one of
the fields okay but that's not the end
of the story because the same years and
shortly after our mechanics comes in but
I think self was the origin of it then
Verna Heisenberg and Paul Dirac now the
British probably the greatest scientist
the 27th we have their eye after
Einstein Paul Dirac who's the one who
put order in quantum mechanics and wrote
all the fundamental equation of the
theory so what quantum mechanics says
well roughly quantum mechanics says that
this this particles are not what we
usually think particles are the world is
indeed made by particles but these
particles are not stones are quantum
objects and what is a part of quantum
object is it's a thing that can that
don't exist sometime in a sense it jumps
from place to place
it's flickers through space-time or
through the other fields and it jumps
probabilistically so it's neither the
Terminator in its motion you don't know
where it's gonna go tomorrow
you know only probabilistic where it's
gonna go tomorrow nor always existing
sort of exists here and then here and
there and you can imagine that the
particles the particles mentally
particle physicists you know when they
talk about electrons they're not really
stones
they're just fuzzy teeny flickering
things jumping around and vice versa the
field where the magnetic field is has
the same property is made by sealians of
little particles flickering around so
the little medic field is the particle
dramatically like all the photons of
course so the photons the field is has a
particle structure if you look at very
small and the particle have a sort of
field like structure because they jump
all over a ballistic
everywhere and the thing I was trying to
be able to produce an idea
think similar what is it most similar
object we have in our experience that we
should like which is like that you know
they came about it some vapor okay so if
you think at all the little droplets
here that they come into being and
disappear I think the closest thing my
imagination toward a set of photons
making a field is so field is not really
a continuous thing it's just
flickering existing and disappearance of
particles so that's quantum mechanics
there are no particles anymore there are
fields which are actually quantum fields
granular fields that exist
probabilistically in the gravitation
field which is space-time but I make it
last step and that's main step at which
you wanted to get to and it's all the
work of me and many of my colleagues
which is this if the fella dramatic the
little magnetic field is made by these
photons as this structurally
construction so is the gravitational
field so it's pace time so space-time
itself is not a continuous thing flat or
curving or stretch or what whatever you
want but it has a thin structure which
is granular it's a minimum length where
granular structure comes in and that's
what the theory of quantum gravity
describes and particularly when we work
is look on to gravity which describes
this fin structure of space-time you see
this is also also this this fabric is a
structural writer's little threads so in
fact it's not continuous these little
threads the weave together to make
space-time so similarly real space-time
in which we live is a field so it can
move and Bend and go this way or this
way and join but if you look in this
small it has a granular structure it has
a loop like structure is weaved by thin
flickering things that exist and don't
exist which are
space-time so at the end all the picture
of Newton the solid
space the soil particle has totally
disappeared there is only one remaining
object which is a quantum field which
exists over itself whose manifestations
are space-time particles light radio
waves everything everything else the
picture of the reality is completely far
away if completely different from its
distance is the clear closest thing
again and imagine about it where have
the particles the space this time of
Newton gone and where is the
concreteness of our experience of the
world the solid table the enduring
aspect of reality of which we are we
have the habit I think that the person
who have answered this question best is
the other great British man I mentioned
at the beginning and who answer this
question saying in a couple of verses
that I am sure you know very well they
were melted into air into thin air and
and part of my horrible Italian accent
in Italian reading like the baseless
fabric of this vision the cloud-capped
towers the gorgeous palaces the solemn
temples the great globe itself yea all
which it inherit shall dissolve fact
hath dissolved
according to the picture of reality that
contemporary physics is given us and
like this insubstantial pageant faded
leave not a rack behind we are such
stuff as dreams are made on our little
life is rounded with sleep
[Applause]
[Music]